- Go!
(mjolnir banging)
(shouting, bickering)
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Bad idea, we'll go one at a time.
It's finally here.
Infinity War is in theaters,
and we get to see all of our favorite
Marvel superheroes back on screen,
but this begs the question,
who's the best Avenger?
All right, so now we have six Marvel superfans
who are here to argue their case
^for their favorite Marvel Avengers.
^- I'm Destinee, and I'm here to fight for the Black Panther.
^Wakanda Forever.
- Blip, blip, blip, blip.
^I'm Kris.
^I'm representing Spiderman.
^- I'm Evan, and I'm fighting for Captain America.
^- I'm Gadiel Del Orbe.
^I'm here to represent Doctor Strange,
^'cause he has cool hand signs.
^- I'm Brenden.
^I'm here to rep Iron Man,
^'cause he's not just a superhero.
^He's also a billionaire playboy philanthropist.
^- Hi, I'm Michelle Feng.
^I'm here for Team Thor.
- First off, his (beep) spiderwebs!
Wait, can I cuss?
(raucous laughter)
- We have to establish some rules first here people.
You can not talk unless you have the hammer in your hand.
Let's do this!
(dramatic orchestral sting)
- Thank you.
First of all, Black Panther is great.
I love Black Panther.
My argument for Tony Stark, for Iron Man,
^is that there are no Avengers without Tony Stark.
Thor, or even a Black Panther, where some of his abilities
are obviously like mystically infused,
he's a lot more fragile.
Tony Stark is just a dude, and look
what he's been able to accomplish.
He can make the people around him better.
You can have ten random people in a room,
and Tony Stark can make them ten superheroes.
Any other Avenger can't really do that.
- And now to Destinee for Black Panther.
- For the culture.
(yelling)
^(smooth elevator music)
The reason why Black Panther, T'Challa, King T'Challa,
as you will address him, is the best Avenger
^is because, where did Infinity Wars take place?
^Wakanda!
He has vibranium.
There is no saving the world without vibranium.
Iron Man is very selfish.
What in that makes a great leader?
^Where did Cap get his shield from?
- Okay, so the shield's vibranium, you said earlier
that, "Oh, you can't save the world without vibranium",
I saw Infinity War, did vibranium save the world?
I don't think it did.
- The reason why Thor is the best Avenger
^is not only does he have the most incredible power,
^he is a great person.
^He started off, he was selfish, he was banished
^because he was so self-centered.
Over the course of the MCU, you see him really developing
humanity and fighting not only for people on Asgard
but also the people of Earth.
- Good person points for our Avengers.
It goes a long way people.
- Spiderman has to be one of the most courageous Avengers.
Homeboy is 16 years old.
- Wasn't he 17?
Last time I checked.
- You can only speak when you have the power of the hammer!
- Okay.
- How ever old he is, he's always rushing into the fight,
he's always out there to help.
^In Infinity War, he jumps on that spaceship,
^goes with that spaceship, he also becomes the Iron Spider,
basically makes a plan to kill one of the Black Order.
He's doing way more than I was as a teenager.
- That's not saying much though, kids.
(laughter)
- He's the best Avenger because he has the most to prove,
and he proves it every single step of the way.
- Captain America is technically the first Avenger.
He was the first one to band everyone together,
^also he's the only one who can actually hold Thor's hammer,
^because he is all pure.
^He's a little kid who got some power and now he uses it
to make the world a better place.
- First of all, Captain America betrayed the Avengers
just because, "Bucky is my friend from back in the day."
And where was Captain America at the beginning of the movie?
You know where was he?
He was licking Bucky's ass.
^All Dr. Strange is gotta do is, "Hey Captain America,
^we're going to teleport to Uranus and leave him there."
He has magic, he could multiply.
Captain America wouldn't know what to do.
- Dr. Strange wouldn't have his powers
if it weren't for Captain America.
- Dr. Strange got his own powers going through the monks,
that had nothing to do with Captain America.
- True, but he wouldn't be part of the Avengers.
- He don't need to part of the Avengers.
- We're talking about who's the best Avenger!
- Hey, but he could be his own Avenger.
- Has he been included yet, is he actually an Avenger yet?
- Not yet, but in the comics he is, yo.
- We're not talking about comics,
we're talking about movies.
- It don't matter!
- Boom!
(dramatic banging)
- Very, very strong, impassioned arguments
from you two young men who have way too much
time on your hands.
- That was a good battle.
- I like this sportsmanship between you guys,
the rest of you, I'm very disappointed.
(laughter)
- So I guess, we need to check with our judges.
Judges, final answer?
- There's nothing in your ear.
- So I think, after I've confirmed with the judges
You each will get one sentence
to say why your character is the best Avenger.
On my hammer, go!
- T'Challa is a man of the people, for the people,
which creates quality leadership.
- Tony Stark is a mortal man without super powers,
who could die at any point.
That bravery, that courage, is what makes him
truly special and the best Avenger.
- Captain America is the first Avenger
and he is a captain, he is the only person suited
to actually lead the Avengers.
- Thor has literally lost everything, his parents,
his siblings, his entire planet,
but he pulls everything together to get Storm Breaker
and literally stab Thanos in the heart.
- But that doesn't do the job!
- He is almost did it though
- That doesn't count!
- T'Challa is a king.
- He's also a god.
- Thor is also a king.
- Can I say Captain America fought Nazis?
- Yeah, Captain America fought Nazis,
and I'm Jewish, that's big for me.
- It's hard to argue with fighting Nazis.
- I mean.
- No one else here fought Nazis.
- Damn straight.
- No one else fought Nazis.
- Can I make one final point?
- No.
(arguing, shouting)
- One sentence, it was one sentence,
you had more than one sentence!
- If it was between who's the best Avenger,
he's not an Avenger yet.
- Okay, real time, Black Panther gets his own category,
so if we're going to be doing it under the guise
of who's the best Avenger, okay,
then for that, based off of the facts
that were stated in the debate.
- Really swaying?
(laughter)
- No, you can't put me up th--
- You ain't got that sway!
- Within my body, I am not allowed to say Black Panther
is not the winner, so what I am going to say is
that Captain America is the best Avenger,
Black Panther is the best Marvel superhero,
and that's where we're going to leave it.
- I just wanna say, just wanna put this out there,
Toby McGuire is the best Spiderman.
(yelling)